this is not a normal food bank
12 weeks ago reverend michael shaw saw
there was a problem brewing in his
plymouth community
his answer to set up a food club
members pay a pound to join and two
pounds to fill a bag
he says it gives them dignity
when they're facing the toughest of
choices
i'm not proud of this i i don't i don't
want to i'm a church minister my job is
to sort of you know help help people
with with spiritual needs however for me
it's also a there's a requirement to
feed people where they are hungry and i
don't really want to be doing this but
this is what's needed by the community
hello you're right
go for it
for mum of 4b
this food club is a lifeline it just
helps with the cost of living at the
minute and
everything's adding out when you go to
the shops and get what you need
you've not got money for trades uh
anything like this and what these days
you get the old little treating that for
the kids
so yeah you know with anything
once you the gas and electric oh my
goodness it's so high
so yeah this this helps
nearly a fifth of plymouth's adult
population is over indebted meaning they
find keeping up with bills a heavy
burden we hear increasingly how food
clubs like this one are becoming an
essential part of how people are
surviving and that's meaning that
organizers in plymouth are having to
completely rethink the entire way that
they deal with the increased demand
on the outskirts of plymouth the daily
food delivery has just arrived the arc
aid redistribution center deals with
supermarket donations before sending
them out to around 35 food banks and
charities the demand certainly isn't
slowing no it's not and every week i'm
being asked by a new group whether we
can support them every week every week
much of the food has reached its sell
sell-by date but john is worried that
increasing costs for us all could hit
donations
my experience with the people of
plymouth is that extremely generous
we've seen that time and time again
but obviously if budgets are being
squeezed people who may have
historically been donating into boxes
and supermarkets may then have been
having to decide well i can't afford to
do this
the community in plymouth like so many
places across the country is responding
and while the government's latest
package of help is welcome it's these
volunteers who are providing instant
help to a growing number of people
dan white at sky news in plymouth